[Musique]
rené richard cyr on se retrouve sur la
scène du théâtre du nouveau monde où
vous allez présenter à nouveau les trois
soeurs de tchekhov vous arrêter à cause
d' accords vide il ya deux ans oui
les arts de la scène c'est toute votre
vie comment vous avez vécu les deux
dernières années avec ouverture
fermeture c'est un yoyo mais nous sommes
des nous on est un tout suspendu à la
même corde de yoyo là on est tous alors
donc j'avais de la difficulté à lever le
poing ou a dit oui mais moi oui mais
nous ce que je trouve le plus dur c'est
pour les jeunes ces gens saignaient
l'école nationale l'année dernière de
limaces clé en même temps ils sortent de
l'école tout l'avenir leur appartient
plus et comme si ce
soit plus difficile pour eux coop que
pour nous mais
c'est pas le concours lexique trait le
plus petit nombre de contrats
[Musique]
entre
lula l'homme de la mancha les bains
centre musical votre malheur sergent
recours maudit on pense toujours à
quelques instants de la catastrophe à la
veille d'un spectacle oui c'est vrai ça
ben oui c'est vrai parce que c'est
éminemment fragile
c'est un art fragile un art de
communication il on appelle ça le
quatrième mur là ici le may a pas
véritablement de mur c'est à dire qui on
est en contact avec les gens à les
samoa les vents les jeudis vendredis
soirs
mais déjà il est des moments et peut le
dire on change tout de là on enlève les
relais chapeau on enlève les rats
bonchamp d'enlever pendrillons on met
leur castres ailleurs parce que je me
dis c'est pour ça que je veux faire je
me plaît toujours à dire faire la mise
en scène c'est faire un casse tête mais
taper dessus de la voie
[Musique]
dans votre excellente biographie
rencontre et avait forcé l'entrée
notamment celle d'andré ducharme à
l'évasion
vous écrivez que vous êtes le meilleur
maniaque sur terre ça veut dire quoi et
en quoi ça vous aide dans votre multi
d'être manière
c'est-à-dire que quand tu sais quand je
prends une oeuvre ça devient mon livre
de chevet je lis je relis je relis je
note c'est là que je dis que j ai
maniaque je suis c'est à dire que c'est
bien précis le perfectionniste à la
limite et où commencer
ça parce que j'ai tendance à être
complice et faire des listes à mettre
tout à fait les ti-cats net mais
assiette que je la vends ce show pour
qui un volume à d'assiette était dense
je suis un petit peu maniaque sur mes
affaires mais en même temps je pense de
nature agréable je pense que non mais ce
que je suis un metteur en scène qui en
actifs briser les gens je vais amener
dans ses derniers retranchements jeu moi
je veux pas rentrer dans son jardin
secret mais gare aux bottes le juger
j'aime beaucoup anne richard cyr le
comédien et je veux je veux me faire
plaisir je parlais de zéro du cahier
dont c'est comme ça que je t'aime et la
scène mémorable
j'ai eu comme un canapé recense les
bonnes slide pad est né en speedo wade a
glissé fun radio
touati
jeunes en quête d'un cadeau absolument
inestimable c'est maintenant comme quand
le cadre m appelle pour jouer dans des
films de fred de méaulte baril ce qui ce
sont des cadeaux formidable pas c'est
pas moi qui ai tant speedo c'est le caïd
parce que quand j'ai regardé cette bd
est
là bien au délà du caïd oui parce que
sinon on ferait plus rien
votre curriculum vitae est époustouflant
ont pu effectivement que les feuilleter
les flux de façon presque
[Musique]
en même temps c'est la réalité du syeeci
ça joue ça a joué trente fois faisant un
autre si je t'ai si je vivais à paris à
londres mais échoue duré pendant trois
ans après que j'entrais points à trois
par année ou être hétéro mais ici on est
condamné à l'action
la réflexion on peut la voir mais
souvent on a le luxe de la voir après on
le pose beaucoup avant parce qu'on y est
on est pris dans une espèce de roulement
de 2,2 fait un succès faisant non
ma mère est décédée à la descente
d'élèves et les tec curieux 6 la qualité
que je souhaite à tout le monde la
curiosité
et une dizaine dans les diamants ne sais
quoi lesquels ne pèsent pas d'un acte à
l'appétit
veut
veut baiser mange tout soit obèse tout
reçoit taux de visite prend toutes nos
qu'une ville prendrait congé lui est à
boudry douce à l'omi qu'attendu du ciad
la vie ne fait pas de cadeau si tu l'as
vu vol
ça c'est bon nous salomé dessus du seuil
à genoux
[Musique]
merci d'avoir volé un peu la vie avec ça
me fait plaisir
[Musique]